c'est aujourd'hui que le casino de
montréal rouvre ses portes alors comme
dans tous les lieux publics des mesures
ont été mises en place pour limiter le
risque de propagation de lakovic 19
le casino était divisé en six secteurs
avec une capacité limitée à 250
personnes alors les joies ne pourront
pas passer d'une section à l'autre
le couvre visage est obligatoire et un
stylet tactile est distribué à l'entrée
pour éviter tous les contacts avec les
appareils de jeux et les joies ne
pourront pas toucher aux cartes ou au
jeu ton d'ailleurs on va parler avec
ligne droite à qui est présidente et
chef de la direction de loto-québec
bonjour mon amour à taire bonjour alors
là on le voit le casino de montréal
rouve c'est le dernier des
établissements de jeu à le faire ça va
se faire avec toutes sortes de
contraintes on en a entendu quand même
quelques-unes
on doit notamment réserver en ligne
avant de s'y rend et ça va faire mais
aussi il faut le dire à 4 heures du
matin hier beaucoup de contrats et là
quand même je dirais pas contraint
beaucoup de mesures qui est mis en place
pour assurer la sécurité de nos clients
et aussi de nos employés on est très
heureux d'ouvrir des casinos mais il
demain il faut on se doit de le faire de
façon que les gens sont en sécurité
lorsqu'ils sont dans deux établissements
donc vous avez raison beaucoup de choses
qui ont changé on parle de ou friture de
casino parce que les gens qu'il était le
13 mars quand les casinos affirmé ne
vont pas tout à faire reconnaître le
casino de mauriac ans qui reviennent
mais à partir de 9h ce matin le casino
est ouvert dès l'entrée au niveau des
stationnements je pense que vous savez
notre casino à marial est divisé en six
secteurs de jeu et l'imprimé mon
stationnement dépendant de comment était
notre réservation on demande aux clients
de réserver leur place pour assurer
qu'on maintient un maximum de 250
joueurs par secteur et donc même dans le
stationnement de pendant dans le secteur
où ils ont réservé mon stationné à des
endroits précis le trajet l'intérieur du
casino est différent pour chacun des six
secteurs mais il demande nous croyons
que nous offrons une bonne expérience
de jules malgré ces changements ouais et
là les gens pourront pas se déplacer de
zon zon et au total 1500 personnes dont
qui pourront se rendre dans le casino
vous l'avez dit c'est ces paris aux
hommes dont six ont de 250 personnes
quelle est la capacité habituellement au
casino de montréal je pense qu'on est
environ 20 à 25% de notre capacité
habituelle
il faut dire aussi que nos restaurants
sont fermés les salles de spectacle les
bords il ya de la nourriture mais c'est
vraiment bien de rupture d'un point
qu'on peut prendre le 15 nov marial est
ouvert jusqu'à 4 heures sauf les gens
11,16 de retrait arrêter des gens pour
rentrer à partir de minuit on sait que
les bords ferme à minuit
nous voulons comme mesure de précaution
s'assurer on ne joue pas ne veut pas
devenir le deuxième arrêt dans une
soirée de sortie
elle confond avec un autre au québec a
été la société d'état qui a subi le plus
durement les effets de la pandémie
je pas connu le 16 sociétés d'état dont
les activités ont cessé complètement
pour un trimestre
il est vrai qu'on a maintenu la vente
des loteries mai pour six semaines
tous nos points de vente de loterie
était fermée donc oui je suis con c'est
que la saq a continué ses apparitions
hydro-québec évidemment continuer ces
séparations
alors oui sur le plan financier les
taxis nous était le plus important
ouais alors tout est arrêté pendant où
elle avait dit six semaines le trac il
m'a permis de savoir ouvrir mais avec un
achalandage qui est moins
j'ai même lu que les pertes de revenus
pour loto-québec pour atteindre le demi
milliard de dollars est ce qu'il s'agit
de chiffres qui sont réalistes
je voudrais pas dire à ce moment ci quel
va être le chif
mais il est évident avec un trimestre de
revenus d'au moins l'impact sonore est
venue de cette année veil vont être très
importants où ça fait le plus mal madame
water notre secteur mais l'illettrisme
toujours été capable de maintenir une
actu
et et de leur prix par nous rendre en
ligne bien que notre réseau de
détaillants représentent plus de 85% de
novembre le kid donc vous voyez pour ces
six semaines la même les lectrices ont
été très impacté
mais les loteries vidéo et les casinos
ont été fermées pour les 3-12 semaine
dernière semaine digne d'une bonne
marche et tout un trimestre et encore
plus parce qu'on nous met dans le casino
de montréal
j'essaie aujourd'hui le toit ou donc on
voit que la le secteur c'est des deux
secteurs qui ont été infectées de façon
de plus important rené pacte énorme et
loto québec ne pourra pas rencontrer les
objectifs des deux performances à venir
aussi moins de dividendes pour le
gouvernement du québec
oui mais avec notre culture et notre
reprise d'activité tant le trick les
appareils de loterie vidéo les salons de
jeux et les casinos
nous avons évidement refaite des
projections de revenus et nous sommes
très confiants que nous pourrions
rencontrer ce nouvel objectif du nouveau
cible qu'on s'est donné cette année mais
il va avoir un impact pas réparer ce qui
a été annoncé par le ministre des
finances dans son budget aux menaces je
vais vous annoncer la suppression de
2500 postes si je ne m'abuse de façon
temporaire est ce que vous avez rappelé
certains de ses employés n'ont pas les
employés qui ont été mises à pied de
façon apparence et lorsqu'on a réouvert
nous établissements de jeu donc on ne
fait qu'un rappel de nos employés
jusqu'à ce moment-là tous les employés
qui travaillaient au casino et dans les
secondes de jeu et pressé velde en plein
salaire mais avec le retour de environ
50% de nos employés il ya eu une mise à
pied temporaire de l'autre 50%
on entrevoit que la situation nous notre
objectif c'est qu'au début de l'année
prochaine donc au mode de janvier nous
pourrions europe
nos activités complètement
quasi-totalement mais il de mal tout
part de l'évolution de la situation que
nous montrons pas les consignes données
par sécurité santé publique
nous avions toujours suivi les consignes
de santé publique on a travaillé très
fort avec eux au niveau de l'irec on a
mis en place pour assurer comme je vous
ai dit la santé et sécurité de nos
clients et de nos employés il nous
allons continuer de le faire mais notre
objectif et des mises à pied temporaires
de six morts en terminant sur une note
tout personnel vous êtes la première
femme pour dire la première femme à la
tête de loto québec
oui une grande fierté pour vous
j'imagine oui première là je dois vous
dire c'est une grande fierté pour être
président de loto-québec
pour moi c'est une société d'état dont
mes parents que j'ai commencé à
travailler à loto québec
j'étais très fier je crois que les
québécois sont très fiers donc c'est une
grande fierté
oui il le fait aussi d'être une
nomination qui vient de l'inter est
aussi pour moi
nakk de confiance que le gouvernement a
justement dans loto québec c'est plus
que moi c'est toute l'entreprise
le notaire présidente et chef de la
direction de québec merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous
merci beaucoup de m'avoir invité